[APPLAUSE]
BONITA STEWART: How many
of you have actually
heard of "The Third
Metric," so we can-- OK.
Great.
But some of you have not.
And so part of
"The Third Metric"
is moving just beyond
money and power.
So I thought, Arianna,
could you talk to us
a little bit about what does
it mean, what does success
look like when you start to
think about a third metric
and what it means?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Well first of all,
I'm delighted to be
here, and delighted
to have this conversation
with you, Bonita.
And I loved our
last panel and what
you said, that I'm
going to query you
on about sacred spaces.
And so the third
metric is an idea
that occurred to me after I
collapsed from exhaustion,
burnout, and sleep deprivation,
which is how I start the book.
And as I came to-- that
was seven years ago--
in a pool of blood,
having broken my cheekbone
and got four stitches
on top of my right eye,
I basically started asking
a lot of these questions
that we often stop asking
when we leave college,
like what is a good life?
What is success?
And why by conventional
definitions of success
are successful.
By any sane
definition of success,
if you come to in a pool of
blood and nobody has shot you,
you're not successful.
So that's when I started
thinking our society
defines success in
terms of these two
metrics of money and power.
We give them different
names, but that's
what it comes down to.
And I came to the conclusion
that life is really not
complete without
the third metric.
It's really like the
third leg of the stool.
The first two metrics
are the two legs.
And you basically try
to sit on the stool,
and you will at
some point fall off,
because it's not sustainable.
The third metric consists
of these four pillars,
and each of the pillars
is a section in the book.
Well being, which
starts with sleep.
Because I love the fact
that Googlers are all
about data and evidence, right?
That's why I have in the book 55
pages of scientific end notes.
Because all the things about
sleep, meditation, renewal
pauses are not kind of new
agey, flaky, California stuff.
They are actually
scientifically-based
performance enhancement tools.
And for all the
skeptics in the room,
look at the scientific data.
All the major universities
now, for example,
have a sleep division as part
of their medicine school.
In fact, I became such
a sleep evangelist
that Harvard asked me to join
the board of their school
of medicine sleep division.
That gives you an idea of
how much I talk about it.
In fact, I gave a
commencement at Smith,
and I told the women graduates
to sleep their way to the top.
And I was a late
convert, because I
came to this realization
having collapsed
after I used to get
four to five hours.
And then I read
the scientific data
and realized that if I
got seven to eight hours,
I would actually be more
productive, more creative, less
reactive, and happier.
So it became a priority.
And just very quickly, the
second pillar is wisdom.
And we can talk more about that.
But everybody here
wants to be creative.
And every creative
person will tell you
that creativity is not the
product of clearing our email
box, or being on
the zone, it's often
the product of
these Eureka moments
which come when we create
some space in our lives
in which to hear
the whisperings,
as Steve Jobs called it,
and basically connect
with some deeper wisdom
and deeper insights.
The third part of the
third metric is wonder.
Being connected with the
wonder, the mystery of life.
Often just the ordinary
beauty of life.
We spend so much
time multitasking.
I mean, you walk down
the streets of New York,
and hardly anybody's
just walking.
People are either walking
and being on the phone,
walking and texting, and also
if they're walking and texting,
the assumption seems to
be that if you are not
texting while walking, it means
you're not as busy and not as
important, so you better
get out of the way.
And I remember when I stopped
doing that seven years ago, I
started noticing things that
I had completely ignored,
like this beautiful
building by my apartment.
And I remember I told a
friend, "This is so beautiful.
Look at the
ornamentation at the top.
When did it go up?"
And she said, "1890."
So what else are we missing?
And the final pillar is giving.
That giving is really part of
a completely fulfilled life.
And it starts with small acts
of connecting with people
that otherwise you might take
for granted in our daily lives.
BONITA STEWART: So in
the book you talk about,
this is not a simple
thing to actually thrive.
You have to know
what you're doing.
You have to think about
it and be more conscious.
And I think for the women-- and
there's even a question here--
but we've all been told now
with this worldwide conversation
on leaning in, how do
we go about leaning in.
And then also this
notion of having
a life where you can thrive, and
just invoke this third metric.
How would you address the women
in terms of those two aspects?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Well first of all,
I think these two are
completely compatible,
which is why Sheryl Sandberg did
a big endorsement of the book,
and actually did the
first conversation.
I've had a series
of conversations
with women like you, which
has been really great.
And Sheryl Sandberg
did the first one
when the book came out at the
end of March in San Francisco,
at the Symphony Hall.
And the reason for that
is to make it clear
that thriving and taking care
of the third metric in our lives
doesn't mean that we
don't have big dreams,
or accomplish big things.
It just means
recognizing that we're
going to lean in more
effectively if we learn
to lean back, recharge
ourselves, and lean in.
It's like a dance.
And if anybody here has a
cat, if you look at cats,
you know what they do.
They kind of-- if
they're going to jump,
they lean back before they jump.
In French, for those
who speak French,
there is a term
called reculer pour
mieux sauter, which
literally means,
lean back in order
to jump higher.
And it's really what modern
science has demonstrated,
which is the need for recovery
time, they need for renewal.
And really, ahead of
women and businesspeople,
athletes having incorporated
these practices.
I was in Los Angeles and
I met with Kobe Bryant
a couple of weeks ago.
And he was telling me how
he has a nap-- sometimes
a 90 minute nap before
he gets out to play.
And that clears his
mind, de-stresses him,
and allows him to
be fully present.
Now when he said Phil
Jackson, their coach,
started having them meditate
and do Tai Chi, and have naps,
they all kind of looked
at the him aghast.
But he was like this amazing
coach, so they all did it.
And then they began to see
the impact it had on them.
So that's really why
there's absolutely
no contradiction
between the two.
If we just lean in without
leaning back and recharging,
that's when we fall over.
And you see so many women-- not
just my own experience-- look
at what happened
to Hilary Clinton.
She literally collapsed, again
from exhaustion and burnout.
And hers was more
serious-- ended up
with a clot in the brain.
And you look around
and you see men
having heart attacks in their
'50s, high blood pressure,
and diabetes, pulmonary
embolisms-- all of these
are stress-related diseases.
And 3/4 of our
health care costs now
are because of stress-related
chronic preventable diseases.
So basically, what I'm saying
when it comes to women,
is women should not just want
to be at the top of the world.
They also want to
change the world.
Because the way it's been
working is not sustainable.
BONITA STEWART: So
it's interesting.
I started tracking, just
learning more about the sleep.
And my husband
said, "I don't think
you're getting enough sleep."
And I said, "Aw."
But then you look at the data.
And then the data tells
you in fact, you're not.
But when you do, it just adds
so much to your well being.
One of the things
Arianna, that you
talked about in the book, which
I think just made me smile,
because I think we all can
hearken back to our childhood,
and when we did have
that sense of wonder.
Can you just elaborate on
wonder and how we can actually
bring that back into our lives.
Because I thought that was an
interesting aspect of the book.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Well thank you.
Because I actually love
that chapter particularly,
because everybody here--
let's just take everybody
in the room-- is really curious.
Right?
You wouldn't be here
if you were not.
You are curious about
everything, from whatever you
can Google, and any
amount of big data,
to finding out
about Mars or Venus.
But we're not really
particularly curious
how about our inner
space, our inner space
exploration of who are we?
Why are we here?
And why do we die?
You know, all these
questions, I find
them completely fascinating.
And I have a lot of friends
who find them fascinating.
So we have a lot of
these conversations.
And if you think of it as
The Onion headline put it--
death rate holds steady at 100%.
So much though we want to
ignore it, it's a reality.
And when somebody dies
who is close to us,
it makes us often
look at our lives
and really kind of recalibrate.
I was meeting with Jared Cohen
upstairs before I came down.
And we were talking about that.
And he told me when Michael
Hastings died suddenly
in a car crash, and was his
age-- 31 I think when he died.
Jared is 32 now.
He said it made him just
recalibrate his own life.
It made him prioritize
friendships, for example.
And whatever impact it
has on each one of us.
So I think these
are conversations
which make us reintegrate the
sense of wonder and mystery
about life.
Wherever we are in the spectrum
of religion and spiritually
doesn't matter.
I have friends of mine
who are religious,
and friends of mine who
are complete atheists.
As Reid Hoffman calls
himself-- a mystical atheist.
He says, "I'm an
atheist, but I'm
very aware of the
mystery of life.
I'm very aware that there's
a lot I don't understand.
And I like the exploration."
So I like the exploration.
And I like the
conversation around it,
because I feel it enriches life
and opens up our perception
to things that
otherwise we would miss.
That's why I have a section in
that chapter on coincidences,
because a lot of
people-- even people are
complete atheists who don't
think there's anything
to life beyond what we see and
touch and feel and smell-- they
love coincidences because it
sort of makes us stop and feel,
is there some kind
of hidden purpose
to what's happening
in our lives?
Because this coincidence
is absolutely amazing.
And some of them are
trivial coincidences,
I have some of them in the
book too, and some of them
are significant coincidences.
But I remember I mention a
trivial coincidence, when there
was somebody taking
a survey at a mall
and asks people to give
them their numbers.
And one person gave him a
number that he made up--
the phone number.
And the server said,
"That's not your number."
And the guy said, "Why
isn't it my number?"
He said, "Because
that's my number."
And so it suddenly stops you.
I doesn't mean anything,
but it stops you,
because what is the
probability of this happening?
So when things happen that have
an incredibly astronomically
high probability
of them happening,
it stops us and makes
us just look at life,
and look at the possibility
that maybe there
is some kind of hidden
purpose and maybe even
somebody with a sense
of humor behind it.
BONITA STEWART: So why
don't we start lining up,
because I know many of you
have questions in the room.
And I'm going to go
through the Dory questions.
But start thinking
about your questions
and line up at the mics.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: And
while we're doing that,
can I ask you a question?
BONITA STEWART: Sure.
Of course.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Because
we did an interview with you
for The Huffington Post.
And you had something
very interesting.
I don't know if
everybody here knows
that Bonita is a ballet dancer.
And when you were in
ballet practice one day--
you said normally you don't
bring your smartphone in,
this is your sacred time.
But one day you just
looked at your smartphone,
and the minute you looked
at your smartphone,
your whole work life included
into that sacred space.
And the rest of the time
you could not be as present.
And I think that's just
a great example of why
it's important for us
to create those spaces
where we disconnect
from our technology
and reconnect with
ourselves or our loved ones,
or the present moment.
And I just loved the story.
You can tell us a
little more about it.
BONITA STEWART: Yeah,
so I've shared this.
But I do take ballet class.
And I just decided
during the break--
once you leave, you do the
floor, and then you leave.
And you take a break
and you come back,
and you do the combination.
And so I looked at my phone,
and I had received a call,
and it just changed everything
about the rest of the class.
I couldn't do my pirouette.
I wasn't focusing
on the combination.
I just decided at
that point this
is the one thing that
is so important to me--
this is my sacred space.
And I'm not going to let
technology invade my space when
I'm taking ballet.
So I just, I made
that as a point.
And I do think that all of us
have to-- especially when we're
24/7 in many cases
with technology--
we do have to be very
conscious about making sure
that we do have a sacred space.
So what is yours, Arianna?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
So my sacred space
is first of all, at night--
and this is one of the 12 steps
I have in the book.
I have 12 steps that I
recommend for people.
And I picked 12
deliberately because we
are addicted to this current
way of being perpetually on,
and even addicted to burnout.
So the first step for
me is picking a time
at the end of my day when
I turn off all my devices
and gently escort them
out of my bedroom.
Because if I keep my iPhone,
say, charging by my bed,
and I wake up in the middle of
the night for whatever reason,
I'm going to be tempted
to look at my data.
And I don't want my day life
to intrude into my night life.
I want to wake up fully charged.
Because again, the science shows
that if you look at your data
in the middle of
the night, A-- it's
going to take you longer
to go back to sleep.
And when you go back to sleep,
it's not going to be as deep
and recharging, because your
brain has started already
processing things you
have to do during the day.
BONITA STEWART: So let's
take some of the questions
from the Dory.
So one question we
actually covered,
just Cheryl's book
in terms of lean in,
but what kind of
meditation do you practice?
And you have a specific
mantra or mantras
that you come back to
in times of high stress?
So what do you do in
those high stress times?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: So
I now meditate every day
in the morning for about 20
minutes, sometimes longer If I
can.
But in the book I recommend that
you start with five minutes,
because everybody
has five minutes.
And to remember
one thing-- there
is no wrong way to meditate.
Because everybody here
is a perfectionist.
You want to do everything right.
So that's where you
have to surrender.
All you have to do is
give yourself five minutes
and concentrate on your breath.
I have specific
steps in the book,
but you don't even have
to worry about a mantra.
You can just focus on the
inhalation and exhalation
I also have an appendix
with 12 meditation apps.
I know it's a paradox
to use technology
to help us disconnect
from technology,
but hey, whatever it takes.
So I have picked my 12
favorite meditation apps,
if you want to be walked
through a meditation.
One of my favorites
is Headspace.
Is anybody here on Headspace?
It's a really great app that
was created by an Englishman who
then became a Buddhist monk,
and then became a juggler.
And it's really great.
And now you know, it's really
become very popular in England.
Even the Bank of
England is using
it, which is part of the
amazing thing that has happened.
In 2013, meditation
became mainstream.
And CEO's started coming out
not as being gay, but as being
meditators.
Like Ray Dalio, the co-founder
of one of the biggest hedge
funds, Bridgewater,
came out saying
I've been meditating
for 35 years.
And I consider it the
foundation of my success.
Mark Benioff, the
CEO of Salesforce.
Mark Bertolini,
the CEO of Aetna.
It is really truly amazing.
In Davos last year
there were 27 sessions
who CEO's about meditation,
mindfulness, et cetera.
Just amazing shift in the
zeitgeist around these issues.
BONITA STEWART: MIchael.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Bonita.
Hi Arianna.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Can we
put the lights up a little,
so I can see you?
I mean, I can see Michael, but
I'd like to see everybody else.
AUDIENCE: Well It's a
pleasure to meet you, and--
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Michael, actually what
would be great if you
tell us what you do,
and also if you
have a sacred space.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
OK.
Yeah.
My name is Michael Peggs.
I've been at Google
for 4 and 1/2 years.
I work in the online
partnership group.
We're essentially responsible
for selling AdSense,
ad exchange, double click, a
lost of sales type products
here.
I started in Mountain View.
And I came to New York
2 and 1/2 years ago.
My sacred space.
I do enjoy a drink
on the weekend.
So probably any bar.
But honestly--
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
What's your sacred drink?
AUDIENCE: I'm into my
whiskies right now.
But um-- my sacred
space is probably
either in Tompkins Square
Park, near where I live.
Or kind of Central Park
with a book of my hand,
just people watching.
New York is great for that.
But my question is,
I think a lot of us
do seek the conventional
types of success,
and arguably they
allow you space
for kind of the third
leg, if you will.
I'm wondering as you were
building your business,
looking back, could
you have built it
to the success it is now with
seven, eight hours of sleep?
I think there's this
constant hustle we all
feel, where it's this kind of
need to work harder and more
often.
Could you have built the
Huffington Post and you empire
to what it is now on seven
to eight hours of sleep?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Well, great question.
And I would say
categorically, yes.
In fact, most of the success
of the Huffington Post
has been built after my wake up
call, in the last seven years.
We are nine.
Years old.
And I can say
categorically, looking back,
that the most
important thing you
can do for a
business, whether it's
a startup or a big
businesses, is having clarity
about your vision of
where you're going.
And for me, it was
very clear for example,
between the two grow
internationally,
and this would have
to become a priority,
and to do it in a way
that would be fast,
which meant with
partners in each country.
We are now in 11 countries.
We're going to be launching
in India and the Middle East
in the fall.
And we're also going to
be launching in Greece,
that I'm very excited about.
Because I'm Greek, in
case you hadn't noticed.
This accent is for real.
And I really believe that having
absolute clarity about where
you're going is often a function
of operating from a place where
you are connected to your own
wisdom and a place of insight.
And I really believe that
about leadership too.
President Clinton
is quoted in my book
saying, "The most important
mistakes I made in my life,
I made when I was tired."
He did not specify
what mistakes.
But in our own ways,
we can all say that.
And everybody who works here,
I mean basically, you're
not paid for your stamina, you
are paid for your judgment.
And ultimately you are
paid for your good ideas.
A good idea is worth everything.
And the evidence is
overwhelming that you're not
going to have a lot of good
ideas if you are burnt out.
You can still operate,
and process things,
and work through your
email box, et cetera.
But your function is going to
be more transactional and less
creative.
So increasingly now, as we
all have so many machines
to do a lot of the work
that human beings used
to do, partly thanks to
Google, we now in fact,
have an even greater
opportunity to be creative,
and therefore a
much greater need
to connect to that place in
us from which we are creative.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Thank you.
And please write
about Tompkin's Park.
In fact, I want to
invite all of you
to write-- tell your
stories of burnout,
wake up calls, sacred
spaces, anything you want.
We'll have a hashtag campaign.
Hashtag how I thrive.
The reason for that
is that I really
believe that we can
get to the point
where we can prevent a lot of
people having their own wake
up calls.
We can learn from each
other's wake up calls.
Why can't you learn from
mine, or Hilary Clinton's?
Why do have to have your own?
And also we can learn from
your story about the ballet.
Or learn from your sacred
space, and get ideas
about what can help us thrive.
And to make it super
easy, I'm going
to give you my
email address so you
can bypass the Huffington
Post bureaucracy.
Arianna-- with one R and
two N's @huffingtonpost.com.
One of the good things
about founding a company
is that you get the
good email address.
AUDIENCE: Hi Arianna.
I'm Desmonique Monet.
I manage one of the sales teams
here in our New York office.
I had the pleasure of seeing
you speak about two years ago,
maybe, at a leadership
event we did for women here
at Google when you had
your previous book in.
I went straight from that event
to one of my respites in Maui.
I grew up in Hawaii.
And had a long time to
think about the things you
shared with us there, and made
a lot of changes ex post facto.
And one of the things that
I've been trying to think about
is how we-- those of us
who manage teams or lead
groups-- can take some of
the individual practices
that you share and
build kind of a team
or a group ethos around it.
I'm curious as to maybe some
things you do with your teams
or the people who work
with you to build that
into the fabric of your company,
of those who report to you
and things of that nature.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Great.
Thank you so much
for the question.
Absolutely.
We are definitely implementing
a lot of these things
at Huff Post,
starting with the fact
that we have two nap rooms.
And we have regular meditation,
yoga, breathing classes.
But also in terms of not
just my own leadership team,
but everybody in the company,
we have an email policy
which makes it clear
that people are not
expected to be on email
when they're off work.
And the idea is if there's
something urgent that happens,
we can text them or call them.
But otherwise, people
need predictable time off.
And if they have to be on-- even
if nobody reaches out to them,
something is different.
You feel you have
to be checking.
You cannot really be
completely disconnected.
So we found that
incredibly helpful.
Also, I find that I have
regular walking meetings.
Instead of having a
meeting in my office,
I just go for 20
minute, 30 minute
walk with whoever, one of my
editors or business leaders.
And we just have our
meeting while walking.
So I have a pair of
tennis shoes in my office.
And it's just really great.
It makes it a completely
concentrated conversation.
The other thing that
we're just introducing
is unless you have a
specific reason why
you need to be on your device,
our meetings are device-free.
I mean, my leadership
meetings went from one hour
to half an hour when I said
no devices in the meeting.
We've given everybody
nice notebooks
where they can take
notes if they want.
Does everybody
remember how to write?
So we are also creating
an well-being committee
with a lot of
companies, to learn
from each other in
terms of best practices.
So I would love to
talk with you if you
want to be in touch about some
of the other best practices
that we are identifying
from different companies.
And I love what you
have at Google--
Search Inside Yourself-- I
think it's a great program.
And actually I just
joined the board of Search
Inside Yourself.
And I really love all the
work being done there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
One of the things
we started doing
as a result of reading a
lot of what you share also
on your blog is no emailing
first thing in the morning,
and really starting
with strategy,
or just meditation, or
reflection, as opposed
to like getting right into that
pulse of the-- fight the email
urge.
So thank you.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
That is fantastic.
That's major.
Because again, there's
so much science
that shows that when you start
your day responding to emails,
you are basically allowing
other people to hijack your best
time-- the time when you
can be most creative.
You're just becoming
reactive and responding
to what other people
consider their priorities.
BONITA STEWART: Thanks
for that reminder.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Courtney and
I'm interning at Google.
And this is my first internship.
And I was wondering
what piece of advice
you would give yourself
when you were starting out,
that you wish you had
known looking back.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Great.
I would tell myself
to stop worrying.
Because I was a big worrier.
I had this voice in my head that
I called the obnoxious roommate
living in my head
puts me down, that
has negative fantasies
about the future.
And I think what I would
have told my young self is,
be in the moment and recognize.
One of my favorite
quotes in the book
is by Rumi, the poet, who said
live life as though everything
is rigged in your favor.
You know how often we
tend to live life thinking
that whatever
happens, immediately
we'll say just kind of life is
not fair, feeling kind of sorry
for ourselves.
And when we look
back at our lives,
very often some of the
hardest things that happen
were the things that
opened other doors
and lead to other
wonderful things happening.
I mean I have so many stories
like that in my own life.
And I mention a few
of them in the book
just to remind all
of us that that's
the same truth for all of us.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Steven.
You talked a lot about sleep
and the importance of sleep.
My happy place is right before--
BONITA STEWART:
Introduce yourself.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I'm Steven.
I work with DoubleClick.
And my happy place is
right before I fall asleep.
So in the past I've
used some apps--
sleep cycle apps--
you give it a window
and it tries to wake you up
when you're in lighter sleep.
Did you study any
of that, or have you
tried any of that
for waking up easier?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
You mean to wake up
when you need to wake
up to start your day?
Is that what you mean?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Well it works for naps too.
But longer--
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Yeah.
Well actually what
I recommend is
that you get enough sleep so
that you don't need an alarm.
And really the science
shows that you can overeat,
but you cannot oversleep.
So whatever the time is that
your body and your mind needs
is the time to give yourself.
I mean, you know, it's not
going to happen every day.
I mean even with all the
evangelizing I'm doing,
I only get it done
about 90% of the time.
And it doesn't matter
where you start.
Maybe you'll get it
done 50% of the time.
There is no wrong
place to start.
The important thing is that
where you want to end up in
is to be able to
wake up refreshed.
And it's not really
as hard as you think,
because you are so much more
productive doing your day,
that you find that it
becomes easier and easier
to actually give
yourself that time.
And you also learn
what to say no to.
And in fact,
especially for women.
I just want to remind you all
that no is a complete sentence.
And that again
helps you prioritize
what makes us more effective,
productive, and happier.
AUDIENCE: Hi Arianna.
Let me bring this down since
I'm a little bit shorter
than other people commenting.
Thank you so much
for your comments.
I'm Ally Martucci.
I work on Bonita's team
on the DoubleClick.org
on the south side.
And I think this is
incredibly time appropriate,
and it's just so refreshing
to hear an executive
at your level talking
about things like this.
The idea that lean in is
not diametrically opposed
to this concept that you have to
lean back in order to lean in.
I think it's great.
I had a conversation this
morning with a colleague--
another Googler-- who
said that he actually
spent a weekend
away with friends,
and they all put their phones
in boxes for the weekend.
And I was like, that's amazing!
I'm going to do that,
and implement that.
And I've already feel like a
few things you mentioned today,
not using your phone
in your bedroom.
I use my phone as
my alarm clock,
which is clearly
not a great thing.
But I'm curious about the wisdom
piece of what you talk about.
Do you feel like you
actively seek out wisdom?
Is it a byproduct
of other things
that you do to seek out well
being and those quiet spaces
in your life where you can
reflect and be more creative?
Or are you actively seeking
out people, places, things
that will drive more wisdom
into your life in general?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Great.
First of all on the
alarm clock, you know,
Pottery Barn has some great
vintage-looking alarm clocks.
They cost $32.
But they look great
on your nightstand.
So anyway, if you wanted another
way to make sure you wake up,
take a look at that.
Or you can put your
phone in another room
where you can still hear it.
In terms of wisdom, yes.
I feel that first of
all, if we recognize
that we have a place of wisdom
in us, every major religion
and many scientists have
talked about that place.
I mean, Archimedes, the
Greek mathematician, said,
"Give me a place to stand,
and I can move the world."
And so we all have that place.
It's just that most of
the time we are completely
disconnected from it.
So the first thing is that
we have our own inner wisdom.
And we all are aware of it.
When we pay attention,
how much wiser
we will become about
people, about what we should
be doing next, then
when we're just
rushing through and reacting
to what is happening.
But also, I do
love reading books
of spirituality,
philosophy, poetry.
In fact, these are the
only books I read at night.
And I read books at night.
I really like books.
I like learning them,
and underlining them,
and I like the
physicality of it.
And also I like not bringing
screens to bed with me.
So basically my bedroom
is a device-free zone.
And also conversations
with people, absolutely.
I particularly love talking to
scientists because for me it's
just really exciting that we
are living at this intersection
where modern science is
validating ancient wisdom.
Like somebody-- I
highly recommend
his work-- is Richard
Davidson, a professor
of neuroscience at the
University of Wisconsin, who
has examined the brains of
meditating Buddhist monks,
and literally has put them
through MRI's, has put
electrodes on their
brains, and has seen
incredible amounts
of delta waves
that have to do with
creativity, happiness.
So again, we have
a lot of data that
can help validate a
certain way of living.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Arianna.
I'm Chalmers.
I've been at Google
for about two years.
I work on our hiring systems.
And my sacred space
is family game night.
I don't let any electronics
intrude on family game night.
So what I was wondering was, we
talked a lot about all of this
in the context of our
professional lives.
But Bonita shared with us
that you're also a mother.
And I was wondering
what you've done
in terms of implementing this
in your own life as a parent,
and also in terms of
educational policy, right?
Because much of this
is very contra to what
we see in childhood
education today.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Yes.
First of all, my
youngest daughter--
I have two
daughters-- 23 and 25.
My youngest just
graduated in art history.
But before they went to
college, and whenever
we would have a meal when
they were in college,
we definitely had a policy
of no devices during meals.
And I think it's
really important
to institute with your
children, the younger they are,
the better.
Because we see
what's happening now.
We go to restaurants and
we see children, really
being with other
children, and they
start texting across the table.
And that is a lot
of consequences
in how their brain develops,
how empathy develops,
so that's really important.
What has happened
with my own daughters
is that they have become real
kind of for believers now.
And we are each other's
set of support buddies when
it comes to
sleeping, meditating,
taking time for renewal.
And it's really
fascinating to see
how-- if anybody here has
been through AA, you know,
you have your sponsors-- so we
are like each other's sponsors.
Like the other day, my
daughter was kind of
tempted to binge-watch
House of Cards.
So she called me up,
and I talked her down.
It's actually good to find-- we
call them also thrive buddies.
It's good to find
a thrive buddy,
when you decide to
make any change.
And I recommend starting with
small, microscopic changes,
whatever you choose
of the twelve steps.
And whenever you begin on a
change, partner with somebody.
And then it's easier
to support each other,
to celebrate when
you're doing it,
and to not judge yourselves,
but help each other
when you backtrack.
BONITA STEWART: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi Arianna.
I'm Holly.
And I'm based here in New York
for at least another couple
of days.
I'm working on the
agency team, but I'm
headed to Mountain
View for a new role
next week, working on
the marketing team.
Thanks for being here.
You're a major inspiration.
And I have a question
about vacation.
And I worked for a couple
of years in the UK,
where I realized that they
have a standard of taking
a month off.
They'll take the whole
month of August off,
and it's just kind of
par for the course.
And that was just so foreign to
me, literally and figuratively.
And then coming back
here to the states,
it's kind of an adjustment.
Like we apologize for taking
two weeks-- a whole two weeks--
we feel guilty.
We stay connected
to our devices.
Are we taking enough
vacation time here?
And this is not kind of
a Google-- sort of like,
I'm not angling for
anything here at the moment.
I don't know if anyone
from HR is in the room.
But really, are we giving
ourselves enough away time?
And those little moments
that we're taking,
obviously so important,
walk in Central Park or time
with a book.
But how about just
a change of scene?
Do the Europeans know
something we don't know?
And do you think that
the winds of change
are blowing here into
the states eventually?
Or are we getting enough?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Great question.
And in fact, I wrote a
blog post about it today
that is on the Huffington Post.
And the title is Lincoln,
FDR, and the Power
of a Good Vacation.
Because FDR, after he was
elected for the third time,
there was a lot
of pressure on him
to make a decision on
what would the states do
regarding the second World War.
There was a lot of
pressure from Churchill,
from England for
states to intervene.
The American public was
completely opposed to it.
So he had this very big,
difficult decision to make.
And everybody wanted
him to make it
right away after the election.
Instead, he took 10 days off
and went to the Caribbean.
And during that time, he
came up with what turned out
to be a brilliant idea
of a land lease policy,
whereby America
would enter the war,
but basically it
would be a lease
in terms of the
funding from the UK.
Anyway, a complicated idea which
the American public bought,
and allowed America
to enter the war.
And this would be
really difficult now.
It would be really
difficult for a president
to take two days off.
I mean, you see
immediately, immediately
it was announced the President
is going to Martha's Vineyard,
the criticism starts.
And there is a very
big truth to the need
for completely
disconnecting, and what
that does to our health,
our mental clarity,
our ability to come
up with great ideas.
And I agree with you.
I think it's very
important first
of all, that everybody
takes their full vacation.
Because Americans are at the
bottom of the list in terms
of actually taking the
vacation that people are due.
I don't know what you have here.
We give three weeks vacation.
And we tell people
they have to take it.
And that it's really
important when
you take a vacation,
to really disconnect.
And I set an example of a
Christmas when I was away.
I got together with two
friends-- Mika Brzezinski
and Cindy Lieber.
We were in different
parts vacationing.
But we all agreed to
do a digital detox
for a week, where I checked
in with the office just twice
a day.
And other than that, I
was completely off email.
So whatever you
need to do to have
as much complete
disconnection as possible,
because 56% of people return
from vacation more exhausted
than before.
Because they tried
to be on vacation,
be with their families, and
stay connected to their office.
So absolutely, we need
to rethink vacations
and how important they are to
the way we function in our work
as well as in our lives.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Arianna.
My name is Jason Vee.
I work under Bonita's org in
the entertainment and music
partnerships team.
My question to you
is about gender.
In terms of the tips that
you've outlined for thriving,
do you think that there are
any fundamental differences
or tweaks for a man
looking at leaning back
to be able to lean in further
and become successful,
or are all these
concepts that you're
talking about from a
scientific perspective
and your own perspectives,
complete gender neutral?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Completely gender neutral.
Absolutely no difference.
I think men and women need this.
I mean every sex needs
them as much as the other.
How many sexes are there?
Only two.
It doesn't matter
what sex you are.
The problem is that sleep
deprivation and burnout
have become a kind of
macho badge of honor.
So sometimes men
have a harder time
incorporating these new ideas.
But if any man has a
hard time incorporating,
they should look at athletes.
They should look at what
LeBron James or Richard Sherman
from the Seattle Seahawks are
doing around sleep, meditation,
and all these things, and how
they actually consider them
performance enhancement tools.
And just one of the
image for the men who
have a harder time disconnecting
and allowing themselves to have
time for renewal, is to watch an
interview that Charlie Rose did
with Andy Murray, you
know, the tennis player.
And Andy Murray was
talking about how
when he's fully
recharged and rested,
the ball is coming at
him in slow motion.
So he's in a place where
he can deal with it,
and have the clarity of
thought to make a decision,
because it's not coming
at him like that.
And I think it's a great
metaphor, because I
know when I'm
exhausted, everything
is coming at me all at
once, and it's overwhelming.
And I get reactive.
And I'm not as able to
operate from my best, kind
of wiser self.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Jenna.
I've been with Google
for three years,
based in our Singapore office.
And I've been tasked with
running around countries where
we don't have offices
in Southeast Asia,
to figure out what
to do for Google.
So I spent most of my time
in Pakistan, Sri Lanka,
and Bangladesh.
These are some of the
most highly repressive,
volatile, corrupt
countries in the world.
I recently moved back to
join Jared Cohen's team.
You mentioned the
Google Ideas team.
So I'm still operating
in that space.
But I'm experiencing some
reverse culture shock.
We're noticing as I watch
the news, how frequently we
complain about first world
problems-- quote, unquote--
and how we can get overly
consumed with these issues
that only we face.
Be it in New York or
in the United States.
And I'm wondering in your life,
as you've grown and developed
your wisdom and kept
yourself grounded, how do you
maintain this perspective?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Well
maintaining perspective
is actually one of the best ways
to connect to our own wisdom.
And looking at what's happening
in the rest of the world
is a great way to
maintain perspective.
In the same way we talked
about death recently,
Socrates said
practice death daily.
He didn't mean it
in a morbid sense,
but he meant it in
the sense that when
we remember that
death is part of life.
And when you go to
Pakistan or Sri Lanka,
and you see that death is much
more present in everyday life,
because of the
level of violence,
because of the level
of poverty, again, it
does put everything
in perspective.
And I think the amount
of worry that we
bring to everyday issues that
don't deserve worry diminishes
when we have that
kind of perspective.
Let me just say one
other thing, which
is that everything we discussed
today, and everything in Thrive
applies just as much to
people in extreme adversity.
Because in fact, the more
adverse the circumstance
of your life, the more you need
to tap into your own resilience
to be able to survive,
and even thrive,
and transcend your
circumstances.
That's why in the
book I even include
examples of people in
concentration camps.
Because there are
people who are able to
transcend even the most
horrific circumstances.
And there are others who fall
apart when they lose a job.
In fact, there is a
very interesting study
in the book by the
University of Chicago,
that tracked what happened
to thousands of people who
were fired by the
Illinois Bell Company.
One of the biggest corporate
downsizings in history.
And they followed them,
and 2/3 of them fell apart.
They became alcoholics,
they became depressed.
And 1/3 thrived and
went on to bigger jobs,
started their own company.
So the same thing has a very
dramatically different impact
on different people depending
on how resilient and connected
with their own inner
strength and wisdom they are.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BONITA STEWART: I think this
will be our last question.
Oh we have one more.
OK.
So these will be our
last two questions.
And then we'll leave
a little bit of time
for you if you'd like
to have a book signed.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I'll make this quick.
My name is Justine.
I'm a community
manager for Google.
I'm actually visiting
from Mountain View,
so this is perfect
timing for me.
I'm curious-- you
just spoke about folks
who might be in
adverse circumstances,
or need to be resilient, a
lot of people who might not
be connected to technology.
I noticed a lot of
your advice revolves
around disconnecting
and unplugging.
A lot of not using your
phone or closing a laptop
during meetings.
So I'm curious to hear
what type of advice
you have that doesn't
necessarily do with technology.
Something that might resonate
with someone who again, may not
have access to
internet or smartphone.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Who
may not have access to--
AUDIENCE: Internet
or smartphone,
or other forms of technology
that sort of speaks
to a lot of the advice
that you're giving.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Absolutely.
So you're right.
I mean, technology is just
one aspect of our modern lives
that makes it harder to
connect with ourselves.
But we can have absolutely
no technology and still not
connect with ourselves.
We can find out other
avoidance measures.
And that's why I think leaving
aside technology, prioritizing
sort of time when we
can have stillness
and silence in our lives,
even if it is five or 10
minutes that we
want to start with,
helps us connect with
that part of ourselves
that so often we are
disconnected from.
And if you think
of human evolution,
we continue to evolve in
terms of our consciousness,
in terms of our thoughts,
in terms of our feelings.
And when we allow ourselves to
have that space in our lives,
it just dramatically
affects how we
respond to everything
that happens to us.
And that's the same
in every culture.
In Japanese culture-- we just
launched the Huffington Post
in Japan-- and
the concept of ma,
which literally
means pause, is just
an essential part
of the culture.
That's why you have
the tea ceremony, which
is a time where you pause from
whatever it is you're doing,
and just really allow that
sacred space in your day.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Thank you.
BONITA STEWART: And
our last question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Arianna.
Thank you for being here today.
You're a big
inspiration of mine.
I was very excited
to see that Bonita
had arranged this talk today.
So my name is Sophie.
I work in the agency
team for DoubleClick.
I come from France.
And in France the standards
are very different.
I thought that coming
over to the US-- I
really admired
Americans, because they
seem to be so much more
energized than we are.
They are on all the time.
And I just maybe I'm
not ambitious enough,
or maybe I'm not driven enough,
but I just think this is crazy.
And so I'm also part of
the Google Guides Taskforce
for our organization
within Google.
And basically
well-being and the fact
that we are plugged
in all the time
is one of our biggest concerns
across the board of our team.
And so we want to find ways
to basically change that.
But I find it although
at very high level,
like DT's, everybody
understands that.
I feel like when you drill down,
managers and directors, some
of them really
don't see the point.
They think that it's
about being lazy,
they think it's about you know--
So I was wondering,
have you encountered
this sort of resistance?
And how did you overcome it?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Great final question.
First of all, let me
just say that the way we
are living and working is crazy.
So there's no
question about that.
It's like, I think
that as we are now
in a period of
transition, which I think
is going to be as
big when we look back
as moving from the Middle
Ages to the Renaissance.
In the Middle Ages,
remember, people actually
did believe that the whole
world revolved around the Earth.
And they really believed that.
Now if somebody's
a flat-Earther,
we don't think very
highly of them, right?
So I think there
will come a day--
I hope soon-- when actually
the collective delusion
that burnout is the
only way to succeed
will be seen as completely
barbaric and completely also
unscientific.
But right now, we
see everything.
We see the resistance
that you're talking about.
And we see early
adopters changing
the way they are living,
not just for themselves,
but for their teams,
or their companies.
So we are living in this
period of transition,
where the reason for my
really wanting to be here,
wanting to be speaking and
writing about these things
that I believe we can accelerate
the transition by sharing
our stories, and
by making people
realize that it's not laziness.
On the contrary,
the people who are
going to be the most
creative, the people who
are going to bring about
the most fundamental changes
are people who learn to
disconnect, and reconnect
with themselves, their
wisdom, and strength.
And so we need new role models.
That's why for
example, I always talk
about people who are
successful, running big teams,
but doing it differently.
And let me just
mention one of them.
Padmasree Warrior.
She's the chief technology
officer of Cisco.
She oversees tens of
thousands of engineers.
We had her speak at
our Thrive conference.
And she said, "I
sleep for eight hours.
I meditate every day.
I paint.
I do haiku.
And every Saturday I
do a digital detox."
And it was amazing.
She's an engineer.
She's not lazy.
She's super successful.
And she's doing it
a different way.
So I think especially for
all the young people here,
those still in college, we need
to publicize these role models.
I've been talking about
her so much on my book
tour, that she
emailed me and said
Random House wants
her to do a book.
I said, great.
That's really what we need.
We need more and more people
to hear that there are new ways
to accomplish, to
achieve, to excel
without burnout, and
without sacrificing
your health, your
relationships, and your life.
Thank you so much.
BONITA STEWART: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]